hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here to tell you about the last
livestream that I'm gonna be doing in
Cincinnati not the last livestream ever
mind you but the last one that I'm gonna
do here and the one that's gonna send me
off on my way to Los Angeles I've been
planning this one for quite some time I
hope some of you guys were worried that
I'd completely abandoned doing them no I
just compounded with how busy I've been
I wanted to make this really something
special in addition to the charity that
we're doing it and for me because this
has been such a big part of my channel
in what I do and and why I do it you
know and so I've been really trying to
make it something special that you guys
are going to enjoy so there's three
things that you need to know number one
number one there's gonna be three
t-shirts being sold for this charity
livestream if you've been with us in the
past you already know what I'm talking
about but if you're new to the channel
as of late I have been selling t-shirts
for charity and then taking all the
proceeds and then donating them we've
raised a tremendous amount of money
through this I think in the past few
live streams alone since we've been
doing it we've raised more money than we
have in the entire year prior to that
given that we started in about August of
2012 and I'm so proud that I can do this
because it gives you guys something to
look forward to in return for your
donation and it helps so much more
because people are more inclined to
donate and give to get these special
shirts so the three t-shirts that are
being made are for myself Wade and Bob
because I wanted to celebrate the
amazing work that they have done to
contribute to my success I mean I
wouldn't be here without them I wouldn't
be here without you guys but I don't
think I'd be anywhere close to here
without Wade and Bob they've been such a
huge influence on me and you know
they've been my supporters since way
early on and I'm so proud to call them
my friends and I hope you guys enjoy
what I've done with them I know you have
I've seen the comments in and the series
that I've done with them so I'm so
grateful that you guys welcomed them
with open arms and saw them for how
funny they are
and how great of people they are they
really care and that speaks to me
because I really care about this and and
to have so many people engaged in this
following is just important to me anyway
while I've been rambling the three
designs that were shown we're fading in
and out over here and now here they all
are so you can look at them each one of
these shirts will be available starting
about a week prior to the livestream Oh
which is going to be on February 22nd I
don't know why I didn't say that before
but it's gonna be February 22nd is the
livestream that's a Saturday it's gonna
be starting at noon and the second thing
that I wanted to mention on my list is
that I will be flying Bob in for this
particular livestream I really wanted us
all to be together in the same room so
it is we we haven't really had that many
livestream where all three of us has
been together in the same room we've
done it before and it has been
tremendously fun it was who's the
coolest experience that I've done in a
long time and I can't wait to do that
again and if you didn't know Bob lives
in North Carolina now and wait wait
still here so he's able to do stuff with
me but to have us all together in the
same room is just gonna be just a joy to
me and I hope that you guys are gonna be
there and you're gonna love it and
anyway that was the second thing the
third thing is we're gonna be doing our
charity for child's play which some of
you not many of you may remember this
was back when I had about gosh maybe
5,000 subscribers we were doing a
charity stream just me actually for 24
hours for child's play and I think it's
very fitting that the first charity that
we've ever done on this channel is gonna
be the last charity we do in Cincinnati
not the last charity total remember this
doesn't mean that charity livestreams
are gonna be ending it's just I wanted
this to be a big send-off for my time in
Cincinnati and you know looking forward
to the future
so beginning with the end it's a good
theme it's good something and child's
play is a great charity and as I've done
charities for very different charity
drives for very different way we've done
so many charities across the nation that
I know that the amount since we started
is way different than the amount that
we've done recently and and you know it
blows me away that you guys support it
so much and it touches my heart that you
guys are willing to put that much out
there for these causes that I truly
support so you know just thank you from
the bottom of my heart for believing in
me when you know sometimes I feel like
I'm spread so thin across 1.5 million
people I feel I'm happy to do this don't
get me wrong this is the best thing I've
ever done in my entire life and and
coming up on two years now I've never
missed a single day's upload I've always
worked and I've always been pushing
myself harder to make better content
more entertaining of taking the
criticism that people have gotten and
I've taken it to heart
not the blatant Kristen but the
constructive criticism to make myself
better and improve what I've done both
as an entertainer in says and as a
person you know and and I want I want
that to reflect in everything in my
channel and I really am glad that you
guys are here to support me in that that
means more than anything in this entire
thing that I've been doing in this
entire channel that we've been building
it it is the most important thing so
sincerely thank you so much for just
being there and thank you Bob and thank
you Wade and you know sometimes feel
like a like an old man in a very young
body because it's been
I don't know last time I had a weekend
myself but it's the most fulfilling
thing I've ever done in my life and I'm
willing to work harder than ever to make
sure that what we do here actually
leaves a mark you know changes the world
because the more people that we get here
the more good we can do and it actually
hurt me sometimes because some people
were messaging me saying that I had
completely forgotten about live streams
or I abandoned my original ideals in
there couldn't be farther from the truth
if anything I want to do more I want to
do even bigger things and so I'm hoping
that you will join me on February 22nd
that's a Saturday starting at noon
because Bob flies in and I have to go
pick him up around 10:30 so it's gonna
be noon it's not gonna go full 12 hours
because once again bob has to fly back
and the only time I could schedule a min
was this but please join us there it's
on the twitch channel all the
information will be provided much much
earlier than the actual livestream we're
doing this three weeks in advance so
just yeah I've been blabbering a bit you
know the things we do here absolutely
incredible
you guys should never ever be
disappointed in yourselves because
together we've managed to do something
absolutely incredible if you don't know
we've raised over $200,000 for charity
over the year in five months that we've
been doing this and almost two years
that I've been doing this channel I'm
just so grateful that you guys have
given me the opportunity I'm gonna stop
blabbering now because I've been going
on way too long anyway the main thing
about this one is that thank you send
off live stream we're all gonna be there
it's gonna be a fun time
I keep getting more it's gonna be a
great time and I don't want you guys to
think that I'm ever regretting what I do
because I love doing this I would want
to do nothing else I am so happy to do
this so thank you guys for giving me the
opportunity it's gonna be the best
livestream we've ever had so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
[Music]